- Enjoy the journey.
Enjoy the whole step, the whole process,
every day that you get up, just strive
for whatever it is you're after.
You can't earn what's in you,
sitting back in a La-Z-Boy chair,
hitting the remote control,
watching HBO and Cinemax.
Intellect can describe them,
but only instinct can find it.
You must understand that the purpose
is an underlying chemistry
that makes you live your life.
Your kids are not going to make you happy.
Your spouse is not
going to make you happy.
A big house is not
We are busier than any other generation
we have seen in the last
three to four hundred years.
If you don't know who you are,
somebody can ascribe any identity onto you
and you will morph into
whatever they want you to be.
If everything went the
way you wanted it to go,
you wouldn't have anything to exercize by.
Because we are starting
every day with the burdens
from yesterday assaulting us in today.
I don't care whether
you're 30, 40, 50, 60, 70,
there's something down inside of you
that's still kicking.
- He's an American Pastor,
Author, and filmmaker.
He's the Bishop of the Potters House,
a non-denominations American megachurch.
He's received numerous honors including
13 honorary degrees and doctorates.
He's Bishop T.D. Jakes and here is my take
on his top 10 rules or success.
(digital music)
- Enjoy the journey, not the destination.
A lot of us delay our happiness.
When I get to this level.
When I get my degree.
When I get the kids.
When I get married.
I'm going to be happy.
Enjoy the journey,
Enjoy the whole step, the whole process.
Every day that you get up, just strive
for whatever it is that you're after.
You know, I'm a goal-oriented guy.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- You don't celebrate when you get to
the finish line, celebrate
all along the way.
Celebrate all along the way.
- [Steve] Yeah, man.
- I know, I put in it, what it takes
to withstand the pressure.
It's like your neighbors say,
you don't know what you've got.
You don't know what you've got
until all hell breaks loose.
You don't know what you can take
until the pressure is
applied to your life.
You don't know what you can endure
until people stab you in the back
and walk away from you.
You don't know how much courage you have
until you've been under
fire and under struggle
and under tribulation.
You can't learn what's
in you, sitting back
in a La-Z-Boy chair
hitting the remote control
watching HBO and Cinemax.
But when all hell breaks loose,
that's when you get to see,
what you've got.
Turn to your neighbors and
say, I'm made of something.
I didn't get to see the design.
I didn't get to see
the architectural plans
but I know I'm made of some good stuff.
I can tell by the burdens I bear
and the load I carry
and the stuff I endure.
I shock myself at what I'm able to take.
It's to just that I shock my enemies,
I shock myself.
They said I was going
to die and I believed it
but through hell and high water,
I'm still here.
When I was in South Africa on a safari,
I was blessed to be on a safari
after I taught for a group
of black billionaires
a seminar about faith and finances.
And they detained me over
and gave me the privilege
of staying out at Jay Paul Getty's place
out there in the middle
of the jungle somewhere
and to go on a safari with my son.
It was amazing, so here I am in between
a zoologist and he's giving
me all this information
about all the animals, their habitats,
their mating practices, how they live,
how they operate.
And sitting on the edge of the jeep
with a shotgun, to protect
us, we weren't hunting
we were just watching, was a Zulu.
The Zulu says nothing at all.
The zoologist explains all the animals.
We visited all the different places
and seen a lot of different animals
but we had not found the elephant.
He explained the elephant
but he could not find him.
Finally the Zulu stood
up and he put his finger
in there and he pointed up and he said,
the elephant is over there.
When he said it to me,
my head exploded, Larry.
It exploded because all
of a sudden I realized,
I'm sitting in between and instinct.
Intellect can describe it but
only instinct can find it.
And from the premise of that ideology,
I began going back through all of my life
and begin to see not only me but others,
how, if they position themselves between
intellect and instinct
and know when to move
to which one, that next big thing,
whether it's an elephant,
an entrepreneur pursuit,
or raising a family,
it is simply over there
if you follow your instincts.
So many times you have a modicum of talent
in an area, maybe just enough talent
to appreciate people who are
really called to that area.
It doesn't mean that
you need to necessarily
go out and do that thing,
you must understand
that the purpose is an
underlying of chemistry
that makes you live your life.
It may not be, you may not have a strong,
let me give you an example
cause I'm messing mine up.
Let me give you an example.
I have talent as a musician,
I can play the piano.
Not well enough to be a maestro,
but I have a modicum
of talent in that area.
But that was not my purpose.
But many, many times we start working
in an area that we have talent
but it's not our purpose.
I tell my kids this, you may start out
doing something that is not the thing
you were created to do.
It may only be the thing that leads
to the thing you were creative to do.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
- [Oprah] I've got ya.
- So you can't don't stop at where you are
as if it were the destination.
When in fact, in reality,
it may be the transportation
that brings you into that
thing you were created to do.
You have to own your own happiness.
Take it away from other
people, demanding that
they make you happy.
Your kids are not going to make you happy.
Your spouse is not
going to make you happy.
A big house is not
Own your own happiness and be responsible
for doing those things that bring joy
into your own heart, independently of life
and people and money
and all of that stuff.
- [Steve] Right.
- It doesn't necessarily
give you happiness.
You have to take
responsibility of that peace
and that joy that lives
inside of your heart
and not inside of your stuff.
The challenge in our generation,
is it gradually through entertainment,
through television, through media,
through every way possible.
We are living in a generation
of the dumbing down of ideas.
Because we have traded
effectiveness for busyness.
Statistics say, yeah, someone
ought to clap on that.
We are busier than any other generation
we have seen in the
last three to 400 years.
We are so busy we are busier than
a one-armed wallpaper hanger.
We are just busy, you'll get it later,
don't worry about it,
it'll hit ya in a minute.
We are just as busy as
we can be and we think
because we're busy, we're effective.
But I want you to challenge
your schedule for a minute
and ask yourself, are you
really being effective
or is your life cluttered
with all kinds of stuff
that demands you and
drains you and taxes you
and stops you from being
your highest and best self
and are you substituting
business and all the chaos
that goes along with busyness
from being effective.
Let me tell ya', a bunch
of scientists got together
and they began to do some research
and they began to determine
that 80% of the things
we do are busy things
that we do in an area
that is not effective.
The average person only
spends 20% of their time
doing the thing that they
are really gifted at,
creative at, passionate
about, excited to do
and the rest of it is all
the digital dumb stuff
that we all have to do
in order to survive.
Just crazy stuff that we're doing.
Wonder what would happen
if we would go from doing
80% of things that are
busy but not effective
and 20% of the things
that are really effective.
If we would switch those numbers around
and only give 20% of
our time to the things
that we have to do and 80% of our time
to the thing that we were created to do.
(audience applauds)
Wonder what would happen to your life.
Now thinK about it a minute.
There's a lot of things
you can take from me
and I would make it.
You could take my suit,
I've got another one.
You could take my car.
I could get another one.
You could take my house.
I could get another house.
But when you take my time.
You have taken something from me
that is totally irreplaceable.
We take all kind of classes
for money management.
We know how to manage our money.
We know how to pay our houses.
We're working on our hair and our bodies
and all this kind of stuff.
We do everything except the most important
thing is to value our time.
It takes time to be creative.
You were meant to be creative.
You were created in the likeness
and the image of a creator
and in that likeness,
in that image you have creativity.
If you had time, you would be creative.
But in the absence of
time and with busyness
and clutter and (imitates phone ringing)
the phone rings, beep, beep, beep.
You all got music playing on your phone,
all kinds of stuff, and no
matter what kind of song
you put on, after awhile
you hate to hear it
cause every time you hear
that sound, you know it's
somebody else wanting
something else from you.
Just taking you away from what you are
gifted and created to do.
The enemy does everything he can
to tear down your belief system.
To destroy your belief system.
If you open up a business,
if you open up a company,
one of the things you have is
vision, purpose, and goals.
And you write them down
so that all of your staff
and all of your team and
all of your customers
can know, this is who I am.
I am defined by my vision, my purpose,
and my goals.
That's my playbook.
That's my creed.
That's what I believe as a company,
as an institution.
I never will forget, several years ago
I toured Nike.
And if you ever get a chance
to go up there and tour,
Nike is absolutely amazing.
I could not find an
employee in all of Nike
that wasn't quick to
tell me who they were.
They never talked about
who they were individually.
They talked about who
they were corporately.
They knew their history.
They knew their background.
They knew who they were as a company.
A philosophy has so
permeated the organization
that even the janitors
will stop and tell you
the philosophy of Nike.
You see the reason that's
important is, if you know who
you are, then you know who you are not.
If you don't know who you
are, somebody can ascribe
any identity on you and you
will morph into whatever
they want you to be and
that's what has happened
with the whole lot of us, some of us
have been 10 or 12
different people, depending
upon who we were with because
we don't know who we are,
we become whoever they want us to be
and then when they leave
us, we are confused
because we have no real understanding,
of who we are.
You say, well I thought
you were done about
believing in God.
I'm talking about believing
in God but I'm also
talking about believing in yourself.
Paul says, I can do all things,
through Christ,
who strengthens me before
he brings up Christ,
he brings up him.
We're so amazed that he believed in God
that we overlooked the fact
that he believes in himself.
I can do all things.
Somebody say, I can do all things.
(crowd chants)
Whew, my God, just stop right there
and say it again, I can do all things.
(crowd chants)
You can be amazing if you believe that.
Wouldn't you sleep good
tonight if you believed that?
Wouldn't you walk around with your head up
and your back straight,
if you believed that?
Say it again, I can do all things.
(crowd chants)
You wouldn't be intimidated
by anybody anywhere
at any time if you just believed that.
Say it again, I can do all things.
(crowd chants)
Can you imagine how
different your job interview
would go if you really believed that
and walked in and they
said, what do you do?
I can do...
(crowd chants)
Imagine if you were
taught that from the time
you were born into the world.
The first thing your mama
told ya when they spanked you
on the behind is, don't worry baby,
you can do all things.
- Because people think I
often, well that's for those
people over there or when
I give myself together,
when I get myself together,
I'm going to live on purpose.
But you say it is
possible wherever you are
right now, Facebook, anywhere in the world
watching us that, even
if you're in the middle
of a disaster--
- Right.
- You can use that disaster for direction.
- Absolutely because it
is thought he disaster,
it is through the
adversity that our strength
is developed, if everything
went the way you wanted it
to go, you wouldn't have
anything to exercise by,
it's a gymnasium of life
where you get the workout,
the resistance to find
out things about yourself
that you didn't know.
I'm stronger than I thought I was.
I'm tougher than I thought I was.
I'm more resilient than I thought I was.
And that self respect stops you from being
at the mercy of other
people to validate you,
to make you feel good about who you are.
- What is something you suggest to add
to our daily routine to empower ourselves?
- Quiet, quiet.
We're too busy.
We're so busy that we don't notice
that we're not productive.
Busy does not mean that you are producing,
and we are just spinning our wheels,
and the great thinking and progress
that we've made in this country,
steam engines, telephones, automobiles,
all types of things, spacecrafts were done
by people who had moments to think.
We're moving so fast at breakneck speed,
and if we get a free
moments, we're all on Twitter
and Facebook and
everything, it's the death
of creativity.
And I would challenge people to go back
to meditation, and if you're spiritual,
go back to prayer, and if you're not,
just go back to just
laying still for a moment
to clear your head, to
hit the reset button,
because we are starting everyday
with the burdens from yesterday assaulting
us in today.
Let's put a comma between all of it.
- I read somewhere, it was an actor
I think said it, that once a week,
he doesn't talk, doesn't talk all day.
- It's just peace.
Yeah, just peace.
Just shut it all down,
and you'd be surprised
what you can hear when you shut up.
I came to deliver a
message to every person
in this room who's had a struggle,
who's had some pains,
who's had some tests,
who's got some creative
ideas, but you've gone
through some really tough stuff.
Let me tell you something,
the stuff you've
gone through, don't pay it any attention,
it's just a sign that the baby is coming.
You're on the verge of birthing,
you're on the verge of birthing,
you're about to give birth.
I want you to touch
everybody you can reach
and tell them the baby is coming,
the baby is coming, the baby is coming,
you don't want to leave me now,
the baby is coming, you don't want to walk
out on me now, the baby is coming,
I haven't had my best idea yet,
I haven't had my most creative moment yet,
I haven't produced my dream yet.
I don't care whether
you're 30, 40, 50, 60, 70,
there's something down inside of you
that's still kicking inside of you
that wants to get out, it wants to live,
it wants to live.
The whole reason you're here today
is because there's something in you
that needs to be fed, that needs to be
stirred, that needs to be electrified,
that needs to be illuminated,
there's something down inside of you
crying, let me out.
(audience cheering)
Let me out, make some
things in this place.
Yes, yes, yes!
We are waiting on your water to break
and for you to give birth to the greatest
idea you have ever had.
Make some noise in this place!
(audience cheering)
Anybody who left you is going to miss it.
They're going to miss it.
They're going to miss
the greatest part of you,
the greatest part of your destiny,
the greatest part of your creativity.
It took everything you
went through yesterday
to get you ready for what you are about to
do today.
You are standing on the verge of a great
awakening or you wouldn't be here.
And if I'm talking to you, make some
noise in this place.
(audience cheering)
I can't hear you.
(audience cheering louder)
I believe there are businesses in you,
companies in you, concepts in you,
books to be written,
paintings to be drawn,
concepts to be birthed,
ideas, creative concepts.
There is something that you could do
that you could think in your life
that would radically change your life.
Somebody could take the
hand you've been dealt
and win with it, same circumstances,
same ideas, they would
do it through what they
thought about your life.
But we don't need somebody,
because we got you.
We got you.
You're the one, you are the one.
I want you to join hands with somebody
for just a minute.
I'm telling you right now,
if you're going to birth
your dream, your calling, your passion,
and the second half of your life,
you can't draw back when life gets tough.
You've got to stand up to it and push.
Get that person by the hand
because there's something inside of them
that is about to happen.
Squeeze their hand.
And when I count to three, I want every
man and every woman that's got a concept,
that's got an idea, I want you to push
with all of your might until dreams
and concepts and ideas
start to birth out of you
in the middle of the night.
You're going to need pens and pads
by your bed tonight,
because you're going to
have to get up in the middle of the night
and start writing down all the stuff
that's going to start
coming out of your spirit
when this thing is ready.
Are you ready?
One, two, three!
(audience cheering)
If you're push it, you can have it.
God bless you, it's yours, so take it!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Christopher
asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepeneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of the top ten
rules had the biggest impact on you.
Leave it in the comments,
I'll join the discussion.
Thank you for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
- If you're looking for
me, I'm not up there.
I'm up here.
You may be seated.
If you're looking for leadership,
you don't always have to look to the front
to find it.
(audience cheering)
Great leadership doesn't start out
on the stage, it doesn't
start out as governors
or mayors, or presidents, or CEOs,
or managers, great leadership starts out
in the back, leadership
starts in the pews,
if you're in a church,
it starts in the pews.
If you're in a business, it starts down
in the janitorial booth.
It starts with menial things.
That's why the bible said,
despise not the day of small beginnings.
You have to understand though,
and I want you to get this in your mind
and in your heart, and most of all,
in your head about leadership,
when you begin to grapple with leadership
and life begins to move your long career
opportunities or, I believe the presence
of the holy spirit
begins to move me along,
because promotion doesn't really come
from the East or the West,
it comes from God.
It is possible for life to lead you faster
than your mind is prepared to handle.
God can move you into such a place
that positionally you are in a state
of leadership, but
mentally and emotionally,
you really haven't got a grip on what life
has handed you.
And if you don't know what you have,
you don't know how to take care of it.
If you don't know how to take care of it,
you can mess around and lose it.
The truth of the matter is leaders
come from ordinary places,
they deal with ordinary issues,
and I'm going to share
some things with you
that I think are very, very helpful
for you to realize.
First of all, I want you to understand
that when you're saying to yourself
that you want to be a great leader
and you want to really go the extra mile,
and you want to do what has to be done,
you're asking for trouble.
You are absolutely asking for trouble.
You're asking for trouble.
And if you think about this a minute,
you'll learn a very important concept that
I think you need to understand.
In the corporate world, in the business
world, they actually pay you
more money as you move up the ladder
with more responsibility.
So, if you are a superintendent,
you might not make as much
as the general manager.
A general manager might
not make as much as
a regional manager, a CEO would make more
than a regional manager.
Let me tell you something,
they're paying you for conflict.
Are you hearing what I'm saying?
It's not enough to have the degrees,
what they're paying
you for is your ability
to manage conflict and pressure
and struggles.
You have to fix the mind
before you can bestow
the blessing, because until they get their
mind right, everything you invest in them
is going to leak out of
the crevices of a mind
that refuses to change.
look at your neighbor and ask them,
do you have a mind to change.
Wait for an answer.
If they said no, drag them to the altar,
tell them they've got til midnight
to get that fixed.
They've got til midnight to dump out
all jealousy, all pettiness,
all unforgiveness,
all strife, all malice, all confusion,
all blaming other people for you mistake,
you've got til midnight to get rid of
every poison that's hindering you,
every inflexibility that's stopping
you from what God is about
to pour into your life.
Woe be unto you if you
go into another year
and waste another year
with the old mentality
while somebody is in
the hospital begging God
for the opportunity
that you have right now.
You better step into this moment.
Lay your hands on your head and say,
give me a new mind.
(audience chants)
Give me a new mind means
give me a new perspective.
Give me a new perspective,
give me a new way
of looking at my situation,
of looking at my
circumstances, get my mind
ready for this year, because
when I get this year,
there's going to be
blessings, there's going
to be opportunities.
Oh yes, there's going
to be some struggles,
there's going to be some challenges,
there's going to be some tests,
but even the struggles are an opportunity
for me to show off the victory if my mind
can handle the change.
You got what it takes.
Storms coming, winds
blowing, lightning flashes,
things aren't fair, things are upsetting,
they're nervwracking, but the very fact
that he allowed it to happen,
seeing as he is the architect,
it is a sign that he's
looked at the specs,
he knows what he put in you,
he knows his grace, he is sufficient
to get you to this moment in your life,
and somebody, oh, I'm about to feel
like a preacher now.
SOmebody in this room knows, you've been
through some stuff that if anybody would
have told you that you
had to deal with that,
you'd have said ain't no
way I could handle it.
But every time you got ready to give up,
there's was something on the inside
that kept telling you, go ahead,
go ahead, go ahead.
If you're in here today,
slap your neighbor and say,
I'm still here.
I've been tried, but I'm still here.
I've been burdened, but I'm still here.
I've been lonely, but I'm still here.
I've been frustrated, but I'm still here.
I cried, but I'm still here.
Somebody, help me pray.
(audience cheering)
Hallelujah, hallelujah, hallelujah,
hallelujah!
High five your neighbor and say,
you got what it takes.
You will make it out of this storm,
you will survive this riptide,
you will get through
this stage in your life,
you have God!
Hallelujah, hallelujah, hallelujah!
I don't know who I'm preaching to,
but I know I'm preaching to somebody.
The devil's been telling you, you're at
your breaking point, but the devil
is not your architect.
He don't know what God put inside of you.
Yeah, yeah!
Ya'll going to come get me up!
(screams excitedly)